these are the new images that the US
says proves Iran was behind the attacks
on two oil tankers last Thursday in the
Gulf of Oman on it the u.s. claims an
unexploded mine was being removed from
one of the tankers to hide evidence iran
denies any involvement the US says that
its new deployment includes security
forces and troops for additional
surveillance and intelligence-gathering
in the region observers believe this
escalation is aimed at deterring Iran
and calming allies worried that transit
through key shipping lanes could be in
jeopardy
Iran has announced it will soon reach
limits on how much enriched uranium it
can stockpile under the international
nuclear deal it's signed in 2015 it also
says it will be able to make
weapons-grade uranium
last year US President Donald Trump
pulled the u.s. out of the deal and re
imposed economic sanctions on Iran and
even though the Americans withdrew from
the deal they still want Iran to comply
with the restrictions we have made it
very clear since this President came
into office and in this sense the
secretary came here that we will not
tolerate an on get Iran obtaining a
nuclear weapon
full stop the European Union and the UN
have called for caution regarding
actions based on the attack on the two
oil tankers for the very latest
let's bring in DW is Oliver salad he's
following this story for us in
Washington good morning Oliver we have
the United States saying very clearly
that it was Tehran that was behind these
attacks on two tankers in the Gulf and
it's released a new photo showing what
it says it's evidence of Iran's
involvement we're gonna bring up that
those images right now can you can you
tell us what we're seeing Oliver in
these photos
well these pictures were shot from a
u.s. Navy helicopter others were shot
from nearby the hull of one of the
attacked tankers and what we can see is
essentially an allegedly staff personnel
of Iranian naval employees trying to
remove the remainders of a mind that did
not explode on one of the tankers you
can also see the shape of a speedboat
used typically by the Iranian
Revolutionary Guards an organization
that is considered a terrorist group of
the United States and these pictures and
these photos published very much are
similar to a video footage that the
Pentagon has published just last week
the Pentagon sees this as evidence that
Iran is behind these attacks some
members of the international community
do share this assessment there's no
common standpoint on this within the
European Union so this continues to be a
very contentious issue okay for the
United States it isn't of course it is
now sending 1,000 additional troops to
the region what's their mission going to
be so the acting Defense Secretary
Patrick Shanahan says this comes in
response to a request by the Central
Command which is in charge of the
military operations of the United States
in the Middle East so they're now
sending 1,000 troops as you mentioned
reportedly the Pentagon is considering
sending up to 6,000 troops in the future
so the big question right now here will
be whether moderate forces or hardliners
will prevail within the US government
and administration Shanahan has stressed
that these troops are only sent to for
defense purposes that the United States
is not aiming for an armed conflict
which is by the way exactly what the US
president has been promising over and
over again he said that the United
States would pull out of conflict zones
of conflict regions which does come in
contrast to the recent strategy on Iran
a strategy of maximum maximum stress and
and impact on Iran Oliver thanks so much
for that for now allgor salad for us in
Washington